ضمن زيارتي ولي العهد السعوديه الامير
محمد بن سلمان الرسميه الى فرنسا من
المقرران يلتقي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بالرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون غدا الجمعه
خلال زياره ايضا سيتراس الامير محمد بن
سلمان بلاده المشارك في قمه من اجل ميثاق
مالي عالميين جديد التي ستعقد في باريس
يومي الثاني والعشرين والثالث والعشرين من
الشهر الحالي وسيشارك ايضا في حفل استقبال
السعوديه الرسمي لترشح الرياض استضافه
اكسبو 2030 المقرر عقده في باريس في
التاسع عشر من الشهر الحالي يذكر ان هذه
الزياره تاتي بعد اقل من عام على زياره
التي قام بها ولي العهد الى العاصمه
الفرنسيه في يوليو من العام الماضي
ضم الينا من باريس المكلف بالتواصل باللغه
العربيه في الخارجيه الفرنسيه باتريس
باريس اهلا وسهلا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
كيف يمكن النظر الان الى الواقع العلاقات
السعوديه الفرنسيه في ضوء هذه الزياره وفي
ضوء ايضا الملفات التي يتفق عليها البلد
شكرا لهذا السؤال
اذا سابدا
بالشراكه ثابته بين فرنسا والسعوديه
وزاره الخارجيه
مؤخرا للمشاركه في
مؤتمر اجتماع وزاري التحالف ضد تنظيم داعش
كان هذا ملف مهم جدا يعني
مصالح مشتركه هدف مشترك بين السعوديه
وفرنسا الكفاح ضد الارهاب
في هذه المناسبه التقت
بناديرها السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان
وتطرقوا الى بعض الملفات من هذه الملفات
الملف اللبناني العلاقه الثنائيه
بيننا كما سابقا
شراكه ثابته تشمل كل الابعاد ونحن نود
تعميق هذه العلاقات السعيده الثقافي مثلا
بمشاريع رمزيه مثل الاولى
الصاعده الاقتصادي وطبعا كما تفضل يشارك
ولي العهد السعودي في قمه
حول الميثاق المالي الجديد وهذا يعني يعني
ان بين فرنسا وسعوديه
ملفات المشاركه على لكن ايضا اهتمام على
العالمي فيما يعترف بالتحديات العالميه في
الملف اللبناني
الى اي مدى هناك تفاهمات او التقاء في
المواقف بين الرياض وباريس سيد باتريس
اولا
سيتطرق الرئيس
قريبا هذا الملف ايضا
نحن على اتصال مستمر مع كل الاطراف التي
قد تساعد في
الخروج من المازق الحالي في لبنان فلن
نتشاورت مع السعوديه بالذات
وعلى هامش
المؤتمر الوزاري حول كفاح الكفاح ضد داعش
التقط ايضا
زميل زميله اللبناني
بو حبيب فنحن
مع حل لبناني على لبنانيين ان ينتخبوا
رئيسا رئيسا اجماع رئيسا
يعين رئيس وزراء ورئيس حكومه لبناني قادر
على اخذ
قرارات اللازمه لمعالجه الازمه الانسانيه
والاجتماعيه في في لبنان هذا
ممتاز ماذا عن السودان السودان اليوم يعيش
منعطف ربما قد يتجه فيه الصراع الى منحنى
خطر جدا وهذا ما حضرت منه الكثير من
المنظمات
الدوليه مؤخرا كيف يتم التفاهم ايضا
والتنسيق في المواقف بين رياض وباريس حول
هذه الازمه
يعني
نتجنب اي ملف وما ذكرنا لكن الميلاد
الاوكراني
ايضا سيكون على المائده بين سعودي وفرنسا
في في زياره ولي العهد فيما ترى بالسودان
نحن عبرنا عن دعمنا لكل الجهود المبذوله
من السعوديه من الولايات المتحده
لوقت اطلاق النار لهدنه
المستدام
لسببين اولا لاسباب انسانيه لمعالجه
الازمه القاسيه التي يعاني عنها
السودانيون حاليا في البلد وهذا يعني ازمه
خطيره جدا جدا
ونهن نقدم المساعده التي قد يمكننا ان
نقدمها
عبره منظمات الحكوميه في الدول المجاوره
الى اخره فهذا نقطه
الاهتمام
بالتقاء
الوطن الانسان ثانيا عبرنا عن دعمنا
للجهود المبذوله من السعوديه على الصعيد
السياسي للخروج من الماسق الحالي من هذا
الحرب استنزاف
لايجاد الطريق لحل سياسي يشمل كل الاطراف
لكن ايضا المجتمع المدني او الفعاليات
المجتمع المدنيه السوداني هذا ما يجمعنا
بين السعوديه وفرنسا وقد اذكر ايضا اننا
شاركنا في مجلس الجوي الى جيوتي لكن ايضا
عمليه اشلاء
الاجانب من من السودان عبر السعوديه في
تعاون وثيق جدا بين السعوديه وفرنسا شكرا
جزيلا لك سيد باتريس
المكلف بالتواصل باللغه العربيه في
الخارجيه الفرنسيه من باريس
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات